(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
(bright instrumental music)
- [Woman] When I play games
on my phone, I turn the volume
way up because it confuses my cat.
- [Man] My dog hates when
I use her as a pillow
but will always me as one.
I'm sure my head is not that heavy.
- [Woman] My dog is scared of my vibrator
so when she bugs me, I
chase her around the house
with it on.
- [Man] Sometimes I make
strange obnoxious noises
just to annoy my cats.
- [Woman] My dog hates
when I have wet hair.
He looks at me like I'm
really offending him.
- [Man] My dog knows when
I'm taking a pic of him
and he hates it.
- [Woman] I torture my dog
by eating a cheeseburger
really slow, she stares
at me the whole time.
- [Man] My cat gets annoyed when I laugh
and it's weirdly hilarious and adorable.
- [Woman] When I can't
sleep, I bother my dog
to make sure she stays awake with me.
It's not fair that she
gets to sleep and I can't.
- [Man] I torture my dog
by putting him in a room
with a see-through door
and petting my other dog
right in front of him, he hates it,
and I know I'm a bad
person but it's funny.
- [Woman] I watch musicals
with my dog and sing to her.
She hates it.
- [Man] I started setting
alarms around three and 4 a.m.,
just to get up and wake
up and annoy my cat.
He hates me and wakes me up
around eight and nine every morning.
It's a battle.
(whimsical instrumental music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)